here's a possible solution for Democrats
if you follow her lead watch if people
pay their fair share if corporations and
the ultra wealthy for example as Warren
Buffett likes to say if he paid as much
as his secretary paid if we reverse the
the tax bill but when raised our
corporate tax rate to 28% which is not
even as high as it was before right if
we if we do those two things and also
close some of those loopholes that's two
trillion dollars right there if we
implement a carbon tax that's an
additional amount of the large amount of
revenue that we can have just last year
we gave the military a seven hundred
billion dollar attack a budget increase
which they didn't even ask for what we
need to do is reprioritize what we want
to accomplish as a nation Jesse I heard
today that she actually has an economics
degree and that's just astounding
because it didn't look like someone who
was versed in economics talking about
that she was looking at her notes the
whole time yeah but you you speak like
like a linguist though I mean she's just
trying to keep it simple for the folks
you're going way over their head I think
what you saying is you know we can pay
for free health care if we do this and
they do this and we do this and if we do
this it's gonna raise two trillion well
guess what guess what it's gonna cost 30
trillion for free health care so she's
not even close to paying for it I mean I
do think she's a nice person and she
means well but I don't think she knows
anything about economics and you know
I'm impressed that she's asking answer
the question I don't think she I think
how are you gonna pay for well what she
said quite clearly was you guys instead
prioritize tax cuts to the point that
you'll drive up the deficit and then you
know Tricia over here says to me all of
a sudden liberals care about deficit
well I'm just telling you her so the
chef isn't pay for well I'm just saying
if you said it's more important to for
us as an American people to take care of
those who are ill who've had
pre-existing conditions than to put more
money in the pocket of the rich one it's
like someone saying you know how are you
gonna pay for this BMW and she goes oh
here's $500 I mean BMW costs at least
thirty five grand
well I'm telling you right now you can
have added money if you were to say you
know what here's our priority we want to
take care of people who are ill major
said if we have an investment here's the
issue nothing that she says pertains to
wealth creation this is always the
difference between the left and the
right her answer her solution for any
kind of monetary issue or gum disease is
taxes it's gonna be axes but if you ask
them how do you create money how do you
create wealth they will look at you and
they will look down at their notes and
there'll be nothing in those knows how
to create wealth instead of how to take
wealth yeah what we need to do is just
redistribute what we have that's
lowering I mean that people fundamental
I don't think most Americans if you push
them will actually tell you that they
want to go to work and turn over their
check to Uncle Sam I think most
Americans really want to keep all that
they have but there is a part of the
population you think about the people
that followed Sanders or the people that
are following her that say no wealth
redistribution is okay yeah that's the
way they want we have too much income
inequality and it's becoming a political
liability for you guys growth growth
growth